my name is Sean moody I'm the director
of Columbia's rare mocha management was
ring I'd welcome you to tonight's
lecture by the new it's Linton that's
from industry Eric Foner
this is the first event our news live
from the archive series the purpose of
which is to connect alumni University's
plumbing university community well as
the wider public the optimist that are
helping their own management library
this case a remarkable account of
fugitive slaves and with the scholars
who study
remarkable objects not necessarily
the term archive is problematic it
evokes authenticity truth mystery and
mistrust all at the same time we look to
the archive in order to know our past
and in order to hold our leaders
accountable even as we raised eyebrows
ease with which space and alter it
more recently the firm has taken on
utopian connotations google promised us
promises us that the new digital archive
is boundless and they've transcended the
physical limitations imposed by paper
and no longer do we need to rely on
human beings to decide question and what
not to say instead we can simply trust
in the ever-expanding cloud so each of
these events will feature a different
object or set of objects and different
scholar but I hope that the series
considers some of the important
questions - what exactly is the archive
what is included in it and what has been
excluded from it and why how can we
begin to interrogate it and new and
meaningful ways we're fortunate that
Professor Connor is here to help us
inaugurate this series but I might pause
and remind you that while the book
gateway to freedom is a new work of
scholarship the object that helped
inspire it has in fact been a part of
the Columbia archive for several decades
and my point here is that contrary to
what you might
- neither fix it's more inert its
ever-changing and enlightened by those
who choose to engage so after that
lecture tonight and we'll have time for
some questions elections but you all
then continue the conversation upstairs
America can manage your plenary and the
sixth floor perception and so with that
invitation I'll turn things over to
write down who is our curator Lehman
traitor for American districts and he's
the coordinator of this series he's got
her two books more powerful the dynamite
and radical line
Alicia
everyone pagers are going that's where I
met socially Psalter father's right
it's both them together has already
received an enormous outpouring of
principled attention there are so many
ways to introduce Eric Foner the winner
of the votes are in Bancroft prizes
dimensional linear apartment process
author of half-a-dozen significant
historical monographs as well as
numerous edited volumes as days as
experts a public intellectual and
inspirations and generations of
undergraduates mentor artists flourish
that many hundreds of PhD candidates and
graduate students but tonight I'm going
to speak a little bit about his life as
a researcher at Columbia effect his name
is synonymous with research even if they
haven't read his books any user of
Columbia library knows his name in fact
doing a search on the library's here
also reach instructions exactly
so reviews of his book from the very
first free soil free love paper free
bandmates in 72 the fireman trial never
had lived in an american slavery
and have always praised his research
methods but by far and away the most
fulsome praise was for his master date
reconstruction america's unfinished
revolution 18 states between the 1877
which was published in 1988 one thing
you were called enough deep research
that is not likely to be repeated for a
generation and another of the sheer
amount of research done for this work
would be enough to exhaust most scholars
the author has examined the wide range
of primary sources on the number
the digitization of Sydney Harbour Games
record the fugitives which offers
transcripts images of the entire
directory fugitives and professor comers
scholarly annotations for those before
the art copy the original
tonight the fugitives is the type of
document that historians dream of
discovery to be revealed again in this
way required the fortunate act that the
books themselves were preserved and
saved it required the passage of times
we can't assert that african-american
history into the tension and research
and most significantly in the waited the
skilled scholar to distill includes into
the larger story of American issue so
please join me in welcoming thank you
thank you joy
thank you then we get right and thank
you very very much I have to get my
little my remarks out of here
thank you tide thank you all for coming
here this evening I I'm going to talk a
little about this book of mine that has
just appeared a couple of weeks ago
gateway to freedom but particularly
about this document here since we're
talking about the archives the record of
fugitives which can be found upstairs
and can be seen upstairs after our
discussion here the book is about many
things it talks about the history of
slavery in New York City it talks about
the Fugitive Slave issue in national
politics it talks about legal cases
involving fugitives and other African
Americans in New York City but the core
of it or that the inspiration for it was
this this document here the record of
fugitives as some of you know it I came
upon it completely accidentally it was a
undergraduate history major who was
working in the Sidney Howard gay Papers
upstairs on gay was an abolitionist
editor the editor of the national
anti-slavery standard here in New York
who later became the editor of the the
managing editor of the New York Tribune
during the Civil War a very important
post especially because the editor of
The Tribune Horace Greeley was such a
nut that he was always flying off with
one mercurial idea after another engaged
job was to keep the newspaper in a more
sane kind of radical Republican path and
many scholars were aware have used the
gay papers for his journalistic career
and this student of mine who was also
employed as a dog walker to walk our
cocker spaniel Sammy during the
afternoons and so I saw her many times
and one day she she was writing about
gays journalistic career and one day she
said you know professor up in box 72
it's a big collection of the gay papers
there's this thing called record of
fugitives I
quite know what it is but you might be
interested in it so I filed that away in
the back of my mind and one day I was up
there I said yeah you know bring me out
box 72 here and sure enough there was
this small notebook very small or two
notebooks really and this is the
beginning of it up here and as I said
it's been digitalized and also there's a
trend a searchable transcription which I
put together because the handwriting is
actually pretty good but sometimes a
little hard to read and I'll talk about
that in a minute but so on the one hand
as we heard the existence of this
document shows what you can find in
archives
it also shows I'm sorry to say how fully
indexed the Columbia archives are
because nobody knew this thing was there
for a year for decades it had been
sitting there for decades one or two
historians had used it it had been I'd
never seen it cited anywhere so we have
to further index all our holdings so
people can make better use of them but
anyway what is this document why is it
important what's in it what can you
figure out from this little find in the
archives well in 1855 and 1856 Sidney
Howard gay as I say the editor of the
national anti-slavery standard
abolitionist newspaper here decided for
reasons that are unknown to meticulously
record the the arrival of fugitive
slaves in New York City at his office
his office way downtown was one of two
centers I don't even like used words
stations as people do because that
suggests a more organized system than
really existed but there were two places
where fugitive slaves were assisted and
sent on their way to the - upstate New
York or New England or increasingly a
Canada over 200 men women and children
their experiences are recorded in this
little these two notebooks for two years
he and he was a journalist so he
interviewed them he talked he asked them
about their owners why they escaped how
they escaped who helped them and he
recorded where he sent them
who we sent them to in other places so
it's a little microcosm of the
experience of fugitive slaves and this
kind of small-scale network really in
New York Court which is part of what we
call the underground of railroad
luckily more than half of these
fugitives arrived from Philadelphia by
train basically having been sent by
Williams still who was an
african-american abolitionist who was
the head of the anti-slavery office in
Philadelphia and so and still kept
records like this also everyone knew
about stills records they are
digitalized by the Historical Society of
Pennsylvania but taking gays and stills
you actually can first of all correlate
the stories of these fugitive slaves and
add information about them from one to
the other and it helps you to expand
still had more information about where
they came from and get more information
where he sent them to and so putting
them together is a way of checking the
consistency of their stories which turn
out to be very consistent and and quite
reliable and anyway this document is a
treasure trove of information about
slavery about fugitive slaves and about
abolitionism so I want to talk to a
little about what's in here and then
what sort of what we can learn from it
the longest entry in the record of
fugitive slaves has to do with the
well-known celebrated Harriet Tubman who
after her own escape from Maryland made
several forays in the 1850s back into
Maryland as you all note and led some as
some number around 70 fugitive slaves
out of Maryland and to freedom in the
north she passed through Sidney Howard
gaz'd office twice in 1856 in the first
and in fact the longest entry and this
thing is gaze discussion with an almost
interview with Harriet Tubman in which
she describes her career her life and
these escapes in May 1856 a recorded
quote captain Harriet Tubman
arrived with four fugitive slaves it's
interesting that he called their captain
Harriet Tubman an unusual title to give
to a woman at that time it suggests that
he knew her or knew of her before she
turned up in his office she in this case
she described leading these four young
men all in their 20s from the Eastern
Shore of Maryland the center of slavery
in Maryland up through Maryland Delaware
and in Pennsylvania and to New York and
she described it this is the typical
this is what you find in this document
they started out on foot from Marilyn in
Maryland on May 3rd 1856 they got to New
Castle Delaware which was pretty close
to where they started and then they
learned that the owners had as she said
raised a you and cry and posted a
substantial reward for their capture and
they hid for a week in what she called a
potato hole which is kind of a root
cellar or something like that I assume
at the home of a free black woman in
rural Delaware Tubman traveled back and
forth to Wilmington Delaware by train at
considerable risk trying to find people
who could help them and finally they did
get to Wilmington and on and they
arrived at Williams stills office in
Philadelphia on May 11th and two days
later they got there they are recorded
as turning up in New York City and Gaye
sent them up to Syracuse by train he
says and eventually they headed to
Canada and in fact three of the four men
who came with Tubman are actually
recorded in the Canadian census of 1861
as living near Toronto so you can
actually use these records to track out
the whole story of these fugitive slaves
later in 1856 Tubman turned up with
another group passing through New York
City now it shouldn't this was it was
typical that these slaves came from
Maryland more than half of the slaves
recorded in this document originated in
Maryland or Delaware
with the eastern slave states closest to
free soil and obviously it was a lot
easier to escape from Maryland than it
was from South Carolina or Alabama or
someplace far away like that but still a
considerable number came from further
away there's a considerable number
listed from Virginia and North Carolina
slaves of every age escaped but most of
them I'm just talking about the 200 or
so listed in this document the average
age was 25 they were young ish and
three-quarters of them were men so
they're young men they were because of
that they were at their prime were in
the prime years of their working lives
and of the greatest economic value to
their owners and their escapes were
rather annoying or lost the considerable
losses to those who owned them now the
this guy asked them what kind of work
you did and they're their answers show
how slavery permeated every corner of
the southern economy they ran the gamut
from plantation laborers which is not
surprising to workers on small farms to
household domestics hotel porters cooks
and skilled urban craftsmen carpenters
blacksmiths and even a man who operated
a steam engine many of them had hired
their own time that is they had lived
apart from their owners and cities
passing along their earnings while being
able to keep some money for themselves
and many of them were able to pay for
assistance in in escaping as we'll see
in a minute some of the owners a few of
the owners actually only a few were
quite wealthy plantation owners one was
a guy named John branch who was a former
governor both of North Carolina and
Florida and had plantations in both of
those states and owned well over a
hundred slaves but a much larger number
with small farmers who only owned a
handful of slaves and as I said for whom
the escape of even one would be a
significant financial loss and many of
them were naan Agra had many of the
owners were non agricultural people the
Mert
Minister everybody in the South owned
slaves to see merchants ministers
bankers lawyers a tailor a tavern keeper
and even a US naval officer now gay as I
said interviewed them why did you try to
run away and the basic motive is some of
them said was they wanted to be free
basically that's the number one thing
they just would tie one said I was tired
of being a slave but most of them
offered more immediate reasons for their
decision to run away and by far the most
common was physical abuse you will
remember the movie last year
12 years of slave about solomon northrup
etc and some people who saw that
complained or commented that the
violence in it was rather difficult to
watch it was kind of this very shocking
violence but while I'm not a fan of
Hollywood history as those have been in
my classes no because I rant on about it
frequently the violence in that film was
real and these fugitives told stories to
gay replete with tales of frequent
whippings and other brutality the words
they used just a couple of you know
great violence badly treated hard master
very severe a very cruel man one called
his owner the meanest man in Virginia
James Morris who escaped from Norfolk
referred to his own or a woman and
McCord as quote a heel of a woman and he
wrote a brief account for gay this is on
a separate piece of paper up in the pay
up in the archives of the treatment that
he had been subjected to this is what he
wrote one meal a day for eight years
sold three times and threatened to be
sold the fourth struck four hundred
lashes by overseer trucked across the
head with a hatchet and bled three days
tied hands and feet and knocked down
with a stick made to stand out in the
cold for hours for punishment without
shoes on second to physical abuse was
the ever-present threat of sale many
fugitive slaves rent as they said or it
decided to run away either because men
their families had been sold just
recently or they were gonna be sold or
they feared they were gonna be sold
sometimes because the death of an owner
or sometimes they had overheard some
discussion about their sale and they
decided they did not want to go down to
the deep south as so many slaves were
being sent from Maryland of Virginia and
took that occasion to be to run away but
these escapes always involved wrenching
decisions about whether individual
family members should go or stay many
slaves is our point in a minute escaped
in groups one of the things that
surprised me in this document was that
you know our typical image of a fugitive
slave is a lone person running away on
foot hiding in the woods in the day
running at night there were plenty of
people like that but actually more of
these 200 in this list escaped in groups
than individually when they didn't
believe in groups these frequently
included relatives generally family
groups husbands and wives brothers and
sisters even in some cases small
children which of course made it much
more difficult to get away but
nonetheless no matter how large these
groups every single one of these people
had left relatives in slavery mothers
fathers wives children cousins and some
but some relative or other many of them
hoped that these family separations
would not prove permanent one told one
guy Charles Carter tollgate is that he
was quote determined to get his wife and
four children out of slavery but usually
there was very little gay or Williams
still in Philadelphia could do to assist
people to get relatives out as I say
many slaves escaped not only in groups
but not just on foot in fact a
considerable number came by see New York
of course was a great support the the
Atlantic coast was just filled at this
time with ships of all sizes shapes and
descriptions running up and down the
packet lines
up and down the coast and there were
these little networks which you can
trace out beginning with this document
of people in different seaports who
helped slaves get hidden on boats and
sent north one particularly active
network was Norfolk Virginia the owners
one newspaper there complained the
owners of ships quote make the abduction
of slaves a matter of trade and a source
of profit in other words there were
captain's who just took money from
slaves and hid them to take them up they
weren't abolitionists they just were a
little sidelight in their business there
was also what was called what he called
a clan a a secret society among the
slaves that helped fugitives find hiding
places until they could get them a boat
and black stevedores and crew members
hid them on boats one of the things as
you know from Melville or other sources
is that sailor was a major occupation
for african-americans in the first half
of the nineteenth century many of the
people who worked on the docks boat in
the Virginia and in New York City were
African Americans who were willing to
assist fugitives so there's just one
example here in April 1855 a slave
mother and child arrived in New York on
a ship from Norfolk having been hidden
by the black cook when the boat docked
the cook went ashore and hired a
carriage to remove them so he was he
took the initiative in helping them in
helping them out Williams still
identified a slave Henry lui known
locally as Bluebeard as the manager of
the Underground Railroad in Norfolk
Louise wife Rebecca lui passed through
New York City in 1856 and appeared in
the record of fugitives Bluebeard
himself later escaped and joined her in
Canada the authorities in Norfolk found
it impossible to figure out who was
organizing these escapes when a ship
from Norfolk to Philadelphia was driven
ashore in a storm in 1855
of leading to the discovery of five
fugitives on board a local newspaper
wrote that they hoped that when the
captain came to trial some clue may be
obtained which will lead to the
discovery of the president directors and
agents of the Underground Railroad in
Norfolk so they just didn't know who
they were
now of course strict state and local
laws prohibited aiding slaves to escape
by sea or any other way
ships were sometimes searched and a
number of captains and crew members were
jailed in 1856 what a newspaper called a
New York Negro who worked on a schooner
was arrested in Richmond Virginia after
the discovery of two slaves hidden
onboard the ship two years later a
Virginia Court sentenced William Bayliss
a captain who carried fugitives for a
fee on his schooner sentenced him to 40
years in prison and bailiffs remained
incarcerated in Richmond
until Union forces liberated the city in
April 1865 but there were far too many
ships to have any all of them or even
most of them inspected one of the more
intriguing figures about whom we really
know very little who pops up in the
record of fugitives and also in William
Stills journal is a captain called
Albert fountain who owned a vessel ran a
vessel called the city of Richmond which
sailed back and forth from Richmond and
Norfolk Virginia to Philadelphia and New
York in the 1850s he often stopped at
Wilmington Delaware to drop off slaves
fugitive slaves there by the and and
there a Quaker called Thomas Garrett
sort of helped them and got them across
the border to Philadelphia
captain fountain wrote Williams still
was not averse to receiving compensation
for his services sometimes he charged up
to $100 per slave so these slaves had to
gather money if they were going to get
on fountain ship he was a pretty
courageous guy
when his ship was about to sail from
Norfolk with 21 Runaways on board
officials arrived to inspect the ship
fountain took out an axe and started as
a picture of this in my book I mean it's
an engraving not an eyewitness one but
of the incident when started shattering
the the planks on the deck to prove
there was nobody down below and the
authorities no not take it easy family
take it easy okay we believe you there
were 21 fugitives down below but he died
doing this he convinced them there was
nobody there and they they left fugitive
slave certainly appreciated fountains
efforts one who Thomas page who escaped
from Norfolk on the city of Richmond in
1856 and came through New York asked
Williams still two years later quote
give my love to Captain fountain and
urged him to visit Boston as there a
number of his friends here who would
like to see him now these records of
Sidney our gay offer a glimpse into the
numerous and ingenious in ways that
slaves employed to escape as I said
there were groups that got on boats many
individually arranged with captives for
their passage many departed by train
Frederick Douglass the most famous
fugitive slave who passed in New York
City that was in 1838 borrowed the
papers of a free sailor got on a train
in Baltimore and arrived in New York
City the next day that was a lot easier
than doing it on foot many of the
fugitives that are mentioned in this
document also took off in by train
Harriet Eglin and her cousin Charlotte
Giles also a Baltimore borrowed $5.00
quote on the credit of Charlotte's
mistress they don't know quite what that
means they borrowed money from someone
saying it was for the owner but they
took the money and bought train tickets
to Philadelphia
another common mode of escape involved
appropriating or stealing their owners
horses and carriages Mary Cummins her
adult son James 11 year old daughter
Lucy and another slave all owned by a
wealthy planter Colonel Jacob Holland
worth of Maryland just rode off in his
horse-drawn carriage one day they got to
Shippensburg Maryland they got on a
train to Harrisburg ended up in
Philadelphia in New York and then
further north and again some of them are
in the Canadian census of 1860 living
near Toronto and of course many slaves
did escape by foot over sometimes over
very large distances one slave Simon
hill from Appomattox County Virginia
told gay I took to the woods and bent my
steps northward and in about two weeks
reached Philadelphia that was a distance
of over 200 miles which he covered in
about two weeks so the this document is
filled with interesting dramatic escapes
by fugitive slaves but it also contains
insights into this network or series of
networks that we call the Underground
Railroad we have to get out of our mind
the idea that there were fixed roots
that there were fixed stations that
there were agents that people knew very
few know and forget about quilts with
secret passage now now forget about that
there weren't any quilts and but there
were these local networks which rose and
fell over time some of them went out of
it the Philadelphia vigilance committee
as they called it disappeared for about
five years and then started up again in
the 1850s but they communicated with
each other and they it was a kind of a
very loose but real network of people
committed to helping a fugitive slaves
when slaves escaped in the south some of
them were assisted by like this little
network in Norfolk or Thomas Garrett in
Wilmington but generally speaking slaves
who escaped from the south did so on
their own and when they were assisted it
was by local african-americans see the
slaves or free blacks orphan that they
just encountered on their way not that
they have some pre-planned route once
they cross the mason-dixon line into
southern Pennsylvania they encountered
many people both black and white willing
to help them on their way Chester County
Pennsylvania in the southeastern part of
Pennsylvania was home to a sizeable free
black community whose churches gave
shelter to fugitive slaves and to
numerous farm families mostly Quakers
who forwarded them to William still in
Philadelphia and then on to New York one
black abolitionist there Samuel Ringgold
Ward wrote that when slave catchers
arrived in Chester County
Quakers through all sorts of peaceful
obstacles in their way while the Negroes
made it a little too hot for their
comfort
Quakers didn't believe in violence but
they had other ways of trying to
discourage slave catchers and slaves
slaves of try to escape appear to have
had the idea that there were people
willing to help them they didn't know
there was a certain route but they knew
there were people in the North willing
to help them and they knew that Quakers
were known to be anti-slavery one
fugitive Henry Cooper who escaped from
Marilyn told gay when I got to the town
of North Chester Pennsylvania I stopped
at a house and inquired for Quakers know
just not gonna do send me to a Quaker
you know and I'll be I'll be okay
until the passage of the Fugitive Slave
Law of 1850 which made this the
rendition of fugitives a federal
responsibility and greatly strengthened
the the procedures for getting fugitive
slaves but then recapturing them until
then many runaway slaves just lived in
southern Pennsylvania working as farm
laborers for these Quakers but even many
who had established comfortable homes
there had to leave when the fugitive
slave law was passed in 1850 they it was
no longer possible to remain there
because the day the Fugitive Slave Law
was retroactive you could have lived
there for 20 years and you still were in
danger of being seized and taken back to
the south now in Philadelphia as I said
you have what they called this
Philadelphia vigilance committee
actually named after the New York
vigilance committee which was founded in
the 1830s and was really the big
gaining of the Underground Railroad the
beginning of the Underground Railroad as
an organ of organizations tried to help
fugitive slaves comes in New York with
the creation in 1835 of this vigilance
committee which was first devoted to
stopping the kidnapping of free black
people and their sale into slavery 12
years a slave talks about that it was
quite common in New York City at that
time and then quickly started helping
fugitives reach of further upstate New
York and as I say Williams still this
black abolitionist was the key figure in
new in in pencil in Philadelphia along
with a few others
the Philadelphia vigilance committee was
where one of the most famous fugitive
slaves was literally unboxed this was
Henry box Brown a slave who hired
someone after his wife and children was
sold to the deep south he hired a shoe
maker actually to put him into a crate
about three feet long and ship him sort
of like by UPS or whatever the
equivalent was back then to the
anti-slavery office in Philadelphia and
for 24 hours he was in this crate it was
transported on a ship on a train he
almost suffocated it was a very
dangerous thing to do
nonetheless this thing was delivered to
the anti-slavery office and Williams
still and some others took a hatchet
opened it up and out popped Henry box
Brown he was called wasn't called Henry
box Brown until later but um and he sang
a hymn of praise when he got out and
then but he couldn't stay there he was
sent to New York Boston and eventually
England way became a fixture on the
anti-slavery circuit anyway as I said a
majority of the people in this book had
come through from Philadelphia and
generally Williams still put them on a
train telegraphed ahead announcing their
impending arrival and gave them
instructions on how to reach Sidney
Howard gays office now at that time the
Train didn't come into Manhattan
it stopped across the way in in South
Amboy New Jersey and then you had to
take a ferry across into Manhattan and
some of gays operatives with
sometimes wait at the ferry for people
coming off the the ferry and the train
one abolitionist from Vermont wrote how
in 1856 he was visiting gays office and
a dispatch arrived from still giving
notice of quote six parcels are coming
by train and before I left the office
that parcels came in each on two legs he
wrote usually the person who met the
fugitives at the ferry or scoured the
docks looking for those who had been
hidden on on ships was a interesting guy
who we know very little about called
Louis Napoleon Louis Napoleon was an
illiterate free black man in New York
City who was the chief operative really
in gays office he would be as I say
meeting the fugitives sending him off to
the upstate New York scouring the docks
and also even though he's illiterate
becoming involved in legal cases it was
Napoleon who got a writ of habeas corpus
for a group of slaves brought this is a
famous case I'm not gonna go into it
here the so called lemon case a a family
called the lemons from Virginia who were
moving to Texas came with a whole
entourage including their children in
their slaves through New York City
because you had to get to get to Texas
from Virginia you came to New York and
got a boat to go all the way around but
by then in 1850 in the 1850s it was
it was illegal to bring slaves into New
York in other words the the law now said
a slave brought voluntarily not a
fugitive these were not fugitive slave
brought voluntarily automatically
becomes free this was the famous
principle to the Somerset case in
England in 1772 that slavery only exists
by virtue of local law and when a person
leaves that that jurisdiction they
become free and that was the case so
when these arrived napoleon found out
and got a rid of hay even though as he
literally got a writ of habeas corpus
they were brought to court and they were
freed the judge said I think it was
seven slaves they were freed well
there's no slavery in New York so you
can't be slaves became a very important
case it was appealed appealed appeal
it's called lemon versus Napoleon so he
was a pretty important figure in these
in these operations we know little about
him except that he was quite active in
an in gaze record book there's a whole
page of payments little payments to
Napoleon one dollar two dollars for the
work he was doing assisting of fugitive
slaves um this little office in New York
City stood as I said at the Nexus you
might say of two parts of the
Underground Railroad
by the way gays wife was herself a
significant abolitionist and Quaker
coming from Philadelphia her father had
been a distinguished abolitionist and so
through his wife he's connected with all
these Quaker abolitionists in
Pennsylvania and then through his role
as the editor of the gara Sounion
newspaper the anti-slavery standard he's
connected with garrison e'en networks in
New England and upstate New York so he's
sort of at the connection of these two
parts of the Underground Railroad and
most of these fugitives was sent right
away New York was a very dangerous place
to be a fugitive slave there were slave
catchers wandering the streets the as
you all know I'm sure but the the New
York was a considerably a pro-southern
city it was linked very closely through
the cotton trade to the slave south and
the the local government was quite Pro
southern and it was very dangerous to be
a fugitive slave in New York City in
fact after the Fugitive Slave Law
several thousand african-americans just
left the city the 1850s is the only
decade in our history where the black
population of New York City actually
declined because of people leaving
because of the Fugitive Slave Law well
they were quickly then sent to upstate
New York and Canada gay directed more
fugitives to Syracuse halfway between
Albany and the border with Canada then
to all other destinations combined
Syracuse was an abolitionist center it
was called the Canada of the United
States because of the anti-slavery
sentiment there according to the
manuscript US Census IRA Cobb one of the
he lists at one point agents of the
Underground Railroad that he deals with
about ten or twelve and one of them is a
Skye IRA cob up in Syracuse you go look
him up in the census he lived in the
same building with the County Sheriff
and nobody seemed to bother the with the
fact that he was helping fugitive slaves
all the time the sheriff just didn't
didn't want to bother with them he
certainly didn't fear arrest for his
activities the head of the Underground
Railroad in Syracuse was himself a
fugitive slave Jermaine Logan who had
escaped many years before from Tennessee
I think he was known as the Underground
Railroad king of Syracuse he had a
business card which he distributed
saying I'm the head of the Underground
Railroad here in other words in New York
it was pretty secret up there it was
totally open totally known he advertised
in the local newspapers anyone sees a
fugitive sent him to me
he held fundraising parties at his house
advertised in the press we're fugitive
slaves 20 or 30 would be there nobody
bothered him and one newspaper
complained the local Democratic
newspaper Logan drives his wagon loads
of deluded fugitives around in open
daylight nobody bother him but they were
there on their way soon to Buffalo and
then across the Niagara Falls suspension
bridge a wonderful bridge that was put
up in 1855 I think which enabled trains
to go right across and once you were in
Canada you were safe the Canadian the
British government refused to extradite
fugitive slaves which became a major
source of diplomatic contention with the
United States in the whole period before
the Civil War the Brits you know I mean
look we all know you know the British
they they made millions of millions of
dollars trading slaves in the 18th
century and then they had a fit of
morality and abolished slavery in their
empire and then spent the rest of the
19th century patting themselves on the
back for being so moral and but they did
stand up to the United States refusing
to send back fugitives who escaped to
Canada or to Bermuda some appropriated
ships by the way Mexico also refused to
send back fugitive slaves from Texas
that was a precipitating factor in the
Mexican War of 1846 anyway
anyway so so get what you had once a
fugitive slave Louis past you had to get
to Canada in order to now the funerals
that they worked gaze office worked
pretty effectively considering how few
people this is another thing by my
estimate there were at any one time
there were no more than a dozen people
in New York City a city of half a
million who was spending a lot of time
held to helping fugitive slaves there
were plenty of people who helped them a
little bit there were these dock workers
who would notify Napoleon if there was a
slave on a ship there were others who
knew what to do
they were black ministers if a fugitive
slave came to a black church they would
know state but the people working very
hard on this were tiny number of people
and but they were pretty effective
although in one case they failed
spectacularly that was the case of
Steven Pembroke a slave who escaped from
Maryland with his two sons two teenage
sons in 1854 he was the brother of
Pembroke of a prominent also fugitive
and who became a prominent abolitionist
James W C Pennington in New York City or
Brooklyn actually anyway they got to
Pennsylvania got to Philadelphia and
were dispatched immediately by still to
New York now professional slave hunters
were notified by their owner and got on
the same train with Pembroke and his two
sons they somehow realized this and got
off the train in Newark unobserved made
their way to New York they were put in a
what was considered a safe house but in
the middle of the night the slave
hunters found them broke into the house
arrested them and they were sent back to
the south after a hearing at 9:00 a.m.
the following morning before a u.s.
Commissioner which didn't last more than
twenty minutes it all happened so fast
that no attorney was present to Rep
present them normally the abolitions
would send an attorney to try to
challenge usually what they have to
challenge is the identity they were you
know that this is not the person that
you you think it is anyway Pembroke was
actually then purchased by the
abolitionists and they raised money but
his sons were sold and basically never
seen again
sold to the South Williams still thought
that what he called a stool pigeon or
trader had revealed the the hiding place
and he stopped sending fugitive slaves
through New York City for a while he
said I don't trust their security system
there for about a year and then he
started again dealing with Sidney Howard
game more because actually Pembroke had
come through with another branch I don't
want to go it's complicated but the
another branch of the Underground
Railroad of New York had botched the
pembo case still never sent anyone else
to them but now started again in 1855
that's when this begins with Sidney
Howard gays office Gabe meticulously
recorded in this document also the money
he spent he you know a dollar fifty for
a train to get to Albany or money that
came in generally money came in from
fairs organized by abolitionist women
where goods were sold and the proceeds
some of them went to this to help gay
and his fugitive but they always were
running out of money they always had a
beg for money and that never had enough
to meet expenses in fact in 1856 cash
received was he risked two hundred and
seventy seven dollars that included in a
but expenses including the paid to
louis-napoleon amounted to four hundred
and fifty seven dollars so there was a
deficit due to Sidney Howard gay out of
his own pocket of a hundred and eighty
dollars as I say one shouldn't think of
the Underground Railroad as totally
harmonious and as successfully organized
in 1855 gay wrote a letter to Williams
still complaining basically about how he
was sending slaves he said there's no
other sure place but my or
that I can advise you to send such
persons those to me therefore must come
in office hours when possible I wish you
would advise me two days before of a
shipment as Napoleon is not always on
hand to look out for them on short
notice the next year he wrote to another
abolitionist in Philadelphia James
Miller McKim who worked with still
saying I hate to complain but I must
state effect still is in the habit of
sending men here by a train that arrives
at 3 a.m. unless it is absolutely
imperative it should not be done to meet
such persons Napoleon has to be out by
one o'clock go three miles take the men
three miles back now Napoleon by this
time you can tell him the city directory
had moved way uptown - like 33rd Street
and it was a good way from the docks
and Napoleon is a very old man he was
actually only 55 but that was pretty old
and he's paid a mere pittance for doing
it three days ago still telegraphed late
Napoleon had gone home and we had no one
in the office to do that duty for him by
the way one of the nicest thing about
Louis Napoleon in the appeal of the
lemon case the judge the the lawyer for
Virginia asked sarcastically to John J
the second the grandson of John J the
founding father who and John J the
second a graduate of Columbia in the
1830s and a major abolitionist New York
in fact the only graduate of Columbia
who became in abolition as far as I can
tell but anyway he s J is this Louis
Napoleon who brought the case is this
the Emperor of France and J said no no
he's not he's a much better man so
anyway this record of fugitives ends in
1856 why I don't know it was dangerous
to keep it he was keeping a record of
illegal activities he stopped but
fugitives kept arriving in New York City
we know from other sources the Fugitive
Slave issue played a major role in the
secession crisis the longest paragraph
in the South Carolina
declaration of the causes of secession
had to do with the North's obstruction
of the Greek capture of fugitive slaves
even though very few fugitives got out
of South Carolina too far this was their
number one complaint against the north
as justifying secession well anyway just
to conclude the Underground Railroad
ends in the Civil War but once the civil
war begins slaves do not have to run to
the north they can run to the Union Army
and as the Union Army penetrates the
South more and more slaves seek freedom
far more than had reached the north
before the war seek freedom as you all
know with the Union Army first dozens
then hundreds and thousands and tens of
thousands the so called contra bands and
the Underground Railroad kind of
disappears William McInnis notice in the
in a newspaper in Philadelphia he says
an end is put to the underbid is the end
of 1861 an end is put to the Underground
Railroad I take this opportunity to
thank the contributors to the Treasury
of the Philadelphia vigilance committee
and to notify them that in all
probability we will have no further call
for their aid in this particular line of
business in New York a writer in a New
York City a writer and an abolitionist
newspaper wrote all the railroads in the
in the north are doing a flourishing
business because of the war except one
the Underground Railroad now does
scarcely any business at all scarcely a
solitary traveler comes along but
incongruous Lee the Fugitive Slave Law
remained on the books until 1864 it was
not repealed until 80 although was not
enforced it was not repealed until over
a year after the Emancipation
Proclamation
during Reconstruction it had an ironic
afterlife Lyman Trumbull the chair of
the Senate Judiciary Committee used the
infamous law of 1850 as a template for
the Civil Rights Act of 1866 which
revolutionized American jurisprudence by
extending to black Americans many of the
Civil Rights formerly restricted only to
whites
to do this he drew on the Fugitive Slave
laws enforcement mechanisms and criminal
penalties and the way it imposed federal
power on the states to enforce a
constitutional right in 1850 it was the
constitutional right of owners to get
back their slaves in 1866 using the same
system of enforcement it was to protect
the constitutional right of African
Americans to freedom which had been
announced in the Thirteenth Amendment
was now part of the Constitution in the
Thirteenth Amendment the act that was
passed that time says Trumbull for the
purpose of punishing persons who should
aid Negroes to freedom is now applied to
the punishment of those who should
undertake to keep them in slavery or as
another congressman said we are turning
the arsenal of slavery upon itself
wielding the weapon that slavery placed
in our hands in the holy cause of
Liberty so this is the kind of ironic
aftermath of the Fugitive Slave issue
that the Law of 1850 becomes the basis
for one of the most important measures
in American history establishing equal
civil rights for African Americans I'll
just end by one other document that
struck me when I was doing this work and
this is the death certificate of Louis
Napoleon which is in the Municipal
Archives anyone can find it he died in
Brooklyn in 1881 four days before his
81st birthday and on his death
certificate enshrined for posterity is
listed his occupation Underground
Railroad agent so thank you very much
for listening
thank you thank you thank you and thanks
to the archives for making this document
now available online and it's well worth
taking a quick look at we have a little
time for questions if anyone wants to
raise it or comments and then you're all
invited upstairs to partake of the
hospitality of the rare books and
manuscripts library yes sir
it would never have happened technology
is irrelevant to slavery slavery a
current literature shows that slave
owners used some very modern technology
on their plantations as well as modern
business methods and unfortunately
technology can be used by any kind of
labor system slavery would have lasted I
think this is not a you know this is
counterfactual history they if this if
the Civil War had not taken place or if
the Confederacy had won its independence
there's no question whatsoever that
slavery would have lasted into the
twentieth century what it still is this
today probably not but I have never yet
seen a plausible scenario for its
abolition peacefully unfortunately so
you know now there are economists who've
studied this and said by the 1830s the
price in the Great Depression the price
of cotton fell so low that cotton
agriculture would have been completely
on economical that's not quite
technology that's the world depression
but you know is that true I don't know
maybe it's true but I don't see Saudi
Arabia giving up its oil production even
though the price of oil is fallen fifty
percent but you know it would have
lasted a long time no question yes ma'am
well there was no central clearinghouse
of information but it's certainly true
that
Fugit yes technology both helped
fugitives and help those capturing them
railroads made it much easy to escape by
the 1850s you could get from Baltimore
to New York and then to Albany in Canada
in a couple of days railroads also made
it possible for the slave hunters to
capture them railroad the telegraph made
it possible to communicate
instantaneously one ship that left
Norfolk it was it was discovered or
heard that they were fugitives and the
they the mayor just wired ahead to them
to the to the mayor of New York and
there were police waiting for that ship
you know so technology can be used in
all sorts of ways but the main
technology so to speak with ads and
newspapers owners would put ads in you
know for the recapture of fugitive
slaves the Baltimore Sun is full of
these ads I reproduce a couple in my
book I think it's any of those on our
website yeah so people who were in Jays
book I found some of the fugitive slave
ads for them and I just reproduced them
to show which because fugitive slave ads
are very useful because they are very
descriptive they describe the person if
you're gonna capture him how are you
gonna know who he is they give us high
his appearance any scars any marks and
what kind of accent he speaks with what
he was wearing so they're quite useful
in figure you know just getting a
picture of these people that kind of
thing yes John
my hardest you know right here the first
page it should it's kind of hard to see
but let me see here
ladies ladies Society Dundee Scotland
sent by s roads Philadelphia 48 dollars
and 66 cents he got 48 dollars 60 cents
from Scotland and then the ladies fair
in New York where they were selling
goods for this purpose 94 dollars and 50
cents and then another ten dollars so
he's keeping right but no I mean I
my feeling is he's keeping these records
for himself that he's gonna so that he
knows how much he how much is coming in
how much there was nobody else watching
him and going over his books and saying
hey look yeah you spent too much money
on this he's trying to keep a record of
what he's spending and what's coming in
so he knows now he did get money from
the American anti-slavery society up in
Boston for the publication of his
newspaper they that's where the money
came from and my feeling is he sometimes
took some money out of that pot to
reimburse himself or to do this but
really nobody else there was no
treasurer so to speak you know anything
like that he was doing it all himself in
one of his wife has a letter that I
quote in 1855 she wrote to someone
Sydney has the Fugitive issue entirely
in his own hands that's quite a lot he's
also editing a newspaper every week but
he's but it's mostly louis-napoleon and
another black man William Leonard
working in his office who are doing that
gays not out on the docks looking for
fugitives he's got these two guys who
are out there what if wendell phillips
in a letter called gays runners he has
these runners who were out there looking
and then he organized but this is three
people then there were a couple of
others jacob gibbs
lewis tap an abolitionist you know as i
say up to maybe a dozen but it's not a
giant operation that's for sure yes
running something like the station yes
John Bigelow not John Bigelow it's I
think like not the famous diplomat John
Bigelow maybe it was John being he was a
businessman and who had actually come
from the north yeah yeah well you know
Washington had an anti-slavery movement
even though it was a city with legal
slavery Bigelow does pop up in here that
he worked with some very secretly
Bigelow actually wrote letters to
William still which still reproduced in
a book in which he what did he he had a
pen name it was like Thomas Paine or
something like that but and he he had a
whole code of thinking you know it's
like these packages you know he'd send
two packages coming and he would also
include in one letter he said I'm gonna
send you letters from now on you can
ignore all of the baloney like I would
never break the law everything I'm doing
is totally legal I'm so you know and
it's kind of thing he put these in
letters in case they were intercepted by
somebody but Bigelow did operate he was
a business man and he seems to have
operated a group in in Washington who
was helping fugitive slaves get out of
Washington and and quite a few managed
to but it was very dangerous
before Bigelow there was a William
Chaplin there who was captured and
basically died in prison in in Maryland
he was captured trying to help some
fugitive slaves escape so it was if
you're in a slave state doing this
you're really running a pretty big
danger you know yes
wait you have to stand up because I
can't quite hear you the acoustics
aren't that great in here so I'm sorry
say it again well that's a great
question
III have a article for last week on the
lowest form of thing on Politico online
you know don't believe what you've read
anyway this is true but it's about
states rights and fugitive slaves and
this is a case where the south wants
vigorous federal action the most
vigorous the Fugitive Slave Law is the
most draconian exercise of federal power
within states and localities in the
entire period before its entire history
in the United States up to the Civil War
it overrides numerous local laws local
procedures it it makes it a federal
crime not only to assist a fugitive but
to refuse to assist a federal official
if a federal official comes Hey look I'm
chasing this fugitive you've got to come
and help me and I say no no no I don't
think I want to do that I'm committing a
federal crime by just refusing to help
him what does this prove it proves that
the south did not believe in states
rights that is a misnomer the South
believed in slavery when federal power
was necessary to protect slavery that
was cool most of the time states rights
were a protection of slavery because
slavery is a creature of state law it's
created by state law so the more the
greater the rights of the states the
less outside interference there's going
to be but when it came to overriding
laws in the north they were perfectly
happy to do that so states rights is not
a consistent southern position and the
Fugitive Slave issue certainly shows
that we have to have one more question
okay okay go ahead right here
people to turn over fugitive slaves
well the Oregon crisis a little
different because they weren't a heck of
a lot of slaves up there at Argonne
running away the Mexican War was caused
by many things I think this was an
irritant I don't think it was the main
cause of the Mexican War but certainly
with the British you start with the
American Revolution where thousands of
slaves ran away to the British and many
of them left with them and obtained
their freedom including you know New
York was occupied by the British during
the war and about 3,000 slaves were left
with the British to the great annoyance
of the Americans in fact George
Washington had a hole he met with the
British commander called in and he said
you know I would appreciate if you'd
look out for a couple of my fugitive
slaves who ran away and I think they're
in New York and cotton said well we're
taking them all with us because we've
promised them their freedom and it would
be ungentlemanly to turn them over and
the Washington was quite annoyed but and
then later with as they say Canada
Bermuda the refusal it was a constant
irritant in anglo-american relations in
the 19th century so you have to give the
British credit despite their being so
kooky that they did refuse to send
fugitive slaves back to the United
States all right anyway thank you all
and do take a look at this